hi there steve kaufman here
today i'm going to talk about public
speaking
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell here
to get notifications
so
first of all i think public speaking
in your own language
is an art
something that the ancient greeks and
romans
were
particularly good at or at least it was
a very important part of their
of their lives whether as lawyers
defending a client or
debating in the senate or whatever it
might be
and so they developed a certain
set of rules
i think public speaking is a wonderful
discipline if you are learning another
language so if you are learning english
and i know many people who listen to me
here
they listen in order to improve their
english
and i think that's a good idea and of
course you can study any of these videos
at link
and learn the words and phrases and
expressions and so forth
but
there are public speaking clubs
uh toastmaster clubs this kind of thing
in all kinds of places around the world
sometimes even in english even in those
places where english isn't the native
language
and preparing to give you know
to talk in front of people is a
wonderful way to build up your
capability in a language
now i
was learning swedish
this is quite interesting i was just
thinking about this subject public
speaking the importance of public
speaking
and i remembered
that
i didn't know when but quite a long time
ago when i was really into learning
swedish and i was traveling to sweden
for
business for my lumber business and i
would always go to bookstores and i
would buy
you know books in swedish
and books where i could find the
audiobook
this was a long time ago where we didn't
have the ability like right now
to
go to
youtube and import things to link or
netflix or
you know even to find audiobooks and
ebooks
that
are matching and where we can import
them into links i have done for polish
and for ukrainian and and for other
languages
these things didn't exist i had to buy
an ebook
excuse me i had to buy an audio book
and then i had to buy the book and read
the book and and
look things up so
in sweden i bought this thing called
practice
practice retorique by euron hay
and i was able to buy the matching cd so
this was tremendous fun for me the only
uh problem was
that there were words i can see now as i
look through the book that there were
words that i underlined that i didn't
understand
but
or i wanted to remember like the batu
der aat in other words it this means i
want to get some of this phrasing
uh so uh debuted right
so you know i'm underlying some of these
things so it was part of my
swedish learning
experience but it also taught me
about public speaking and in fact
i had to give a speech to the swedish
i can't remember what it was i think was
they have a in in carlstad every year
the swedish timber trade has an
international conference where
suppliers and customers and people
involved in the timber business from all
around the world come
and they asked me to give a talk so i
said fine i'd give a talk
and so then i referred to what i had
learned here
and then i thought to myself well you
know i can
you know not many people listening to me
speak swedish and there's not much point
in quoting this
in swedish and i was curious to see
if by any chance this book had been
translated into english so i googled
euron hague practice rhetoric
and lo and behold i found an article
that i had submitted to a self-help
website in 2007
the website was called pick the brain
and there it is
it says
nail your next presentation with these
classic principles of public speaking
november the 5th
2007
so that is 13 years ago
and
at that time i was
obviously we were starting link and we
wanted to generate some traffic and i
was out there trying to get guest posts
on people's blogs and stuff like that
but i'm going to post a link to this
in the description box
but i point out many of the things this
is a very good book i'm i'm just
disappointed that it's not available in
english uh i should have actually
checked to see if it's available in
in
ebook format so that it can be imported
into link along with the audio
but he references the greeks he rep and
romans he represents you know
you know churchill or or
modern people who are good at public
speaking and he does sort of hit on the
highlights which i'm going to do for you
now
and i'm going to cheat by uh you know
going back to what i wrote back then 13
years ago so
you know you be they and they had terms
in the ancient world for the different
parts of your presentation so it begins
with the exordium which is sort of the
introduction
and as he points out in his book like
many people are concerned about
how do you start the speech and he says
it's really not very important the start
of the speech is all about
just getting people to like you and so
therefore if you spill your water you
know glass or or you notice some people
in the audience that you know um you
know especially if you're visiting like
if if i was up in carlstad then i might
say oh it's nice to be here with banked
and with
kister and all these friends in the
swedish timber industry to create some
connection that's really all you want to
achieve get them to like you and also
establish that you have some
authority in the field
so you know in my example i would have
said you know that i'm happy to be here
amongst these friends and that
you know i have been in the timber trade
for whatever you know 30 years and i
can't remember if i was talking about
japan or what i was talking about but i
would like to establish the fact that
not only am a nice guy because i spilt
my water
and i know some people in the audience
but also i know something i know what
i'm talking about so i'm somebody you
should be listening to and that's all
you do in this exordium which is the
first part of it
so i then say having earned the listener
sympathy and convince them that you are
someone that they might believe or trust
now you tell them what you're going to
talk about so this is the narazio the
narration you here is what i'm going to
be talking about okay and there's a
little more detail here in this article
and you saw you you spell out the
details of what your your
presentation is now where i was watching
earlier
the uh
the uh discussions in the in the u.s
senate and of course
the speakers are trying to make their
case and stuff like that and so you
present the facts the story the
narration
and so that's the second thing after
you've
gained their sympathy that's part number
one then part number two you sort of
tell the story that you've got to the
details the story
then
the next is supposed to be what they
call the refutation where you come and
point out the counter arguments so you
present all this is we think this that
and the other and stuff but then what
about the counter arguments what about
this so you present these counter
arguments
and
of course you destroy them
you know these
counter arguments can all be easily
refuted so you refute you put these
counter-mark outer arguments up there
and then you just
bang you bomb them
and then
the last part of the presentation is
what they call the pero ratio which is
where you make a final emotional appeal
okay so basically that's it you begin by
making people like you
and establish the fact that you are
someone they should trust and believe
the second part you explain
the or sort of you you provide the
narration here are the facts here's a
story here's what i think is important
here's the cause that i'm
trying to persuade you off
then in the third part you put up
potential
counter arguments and destroy them
and then you end up with an emotional
appeal
and
i found that when i have a uh
talk to give if i have some kind of
format like that that i can slot my
ideas into it's easier to prepare the
speech
and i know where i am leading the
audience they don't know what's coming i
do
and i find that gives me a sense of
control over my audience i know where
i'm leading them at every step of the
way
now
each one of these sections can have
parts to them you might have for example
i had my experience in seance poe in
fact in paris at the
political science institute we were
taught to have these
balanced expose you know first part
second part so in presenting your ideas
you could have part one
and then you can have you know you can
expand on it a bit and then of course
you have the counter argument so there's
different ways you can refine it but the
idea that you have
an approach that says here i am i'm a
nice guy you should believe me
here's a story that i have to tell you
here are the counter arguments and they
hold no water
and here's my final emotional appeal
is a format that i have found to be very
effective and it gives you confidence if
you know what it is you're going to say
and how you're going to say it it helps
you organize your ideas and it gives you
confidence
so
with that you can find a reference here
to the article that i submitted back in
2007
if you want to explore this in greater
detail